foreign
folks welcome to rational science the
only site on the internet that does
physics rationally and probably wasted
your time coming here today because I'm
going to be talking about
nothing
now how long can that take uh zero
seconds
anyways we're going to be answering some
questions at the end of the show but we
begin again as always with our
Extinction segment what is that all
about well uh we suggest here we
theorize we argue here that we are the
last generations of humans on Earth
I don't know how long it'll last maybe
another 10 20 30 years at most I have no
idea I can't tell you exactly when I'm
saying we're very close to the end and
that there is nothing that we can do
about it Zero D nothing okay
um what's going to happen what's going
to cause our Extinction uh comets gonna
hit us uh climate change
uh no it's uh the global economy global
economy will not Maine but Willow
collapse there is nothing we can do
about it uh it's guaranteed just like
it's guaranteed that
um humans will not overpopulate the
Earth you know we're probably going to
have another billion more people by the
time Extinction comes around maybe we'll
reach maybe maybe right about 9 billion
people on the planet and that's going to
be it and that's going to be part of the
reason that we stop our economic growth
as well aside from the fact that uh
there is a qualitative thing going on as
well which is uh you know for 200 000
years maybe 300 000 years since the
beginning of our species we were for the
most part Hunter gathers maybe 90 95 of
that time uh about 10 15
000 years ago we went into agriculture
farming about two to three hundred years
ago we went into uh Manufacturing in
industry
and about maybe 30 40 50 years ago uh we
went into services
and there's almost no Hunter Gathering
today I don't think there's any real
Hunter Gathering even the pygmies in the
jungles have a cell phone today so there
there's no real Hunter Gathering uh
farming is being done by corporations
for the most part or getting there you
know eventually if we keep on the path
we're on today it's all going to be done
by corporations big corporations
agricultural corporations
and uh the workers will have no other
choice but to be
um working in either manufacturing or
services but services are I'm sorry
manufacturing is dying okay because
we're producing this more efficiently as
they as time goes by we try to be more
efficient companies compete against each
other and so they put more efficient
processes on the line and that is going
to push everybody into services
and services is another word for
unemployment
person who works in Services is doing
unemployment he's not he's not really
working he's not in direct contact with
nature with food
and food is all we need to live to stay
one one more day alive so here we have a
situation where you have um people who
are working in things in activities
that are not producing food see in the
old days we produce food directly the
guy went there with a spear and killed
an animal and lived one more day and
we're not there today anymore today we
depend on someone else to produce the
food for us and all we're doing is
passing money around giving it to the
person who produces food so that he
feeds us
and when that cycle is interrupted
that's the end of all of us and that's
what I think will happen when the global
economy collapses Global okay anyways uh
so we look at things related to
Extinction some signs out there some
Trends and how they're related to
Extinction okay and here's one Trend
that's happening these days is that
people are working from home
and there's one file says uh 50 year old
NYU Professor went viral for telling
young folks that they need to be out of
the house for success but his advice got
blasted by 2025 36 million Americans may
be clocking in from the comfort of their
homes
okay so people are moving into this mode
in which they work from home
um but then I looked it up and here's
this McKinsey report it says
um the most striking figure to emerge
from this research is 58 percent
that's the number of Americans who
reported having the opportunity to what
work from home at least once one day a
week 35 percent of respondents report
having an option to work from home five
days a week etc etc putting is uh the
people want to work from home and the
problem I had with this uh little report
was it says over there it says in every
part of the country and sector of the
economy including traditionally enabled
blue-collar jobs
I had a problem with that
um and yeah I'll tell you why because
I'm saying that you cannot work for from
home from True genuine Blue Collar jobs
you know manufacturing jobs industry
jobs
here's the um from that same article it
gives you a listing of the jobs that
people are working from home lately okay
or at least getting into that mode in
which they work from home okay uh give
me a second here when on the other side
there we go
and if you look at these jobs the
occupations and I'm just going to put a
couple examples here look at the bottom
fifth from the bottoms as farming
fishing and Forestry I'm not sure you
can do a lot of farming from your house
you know on your uh carpet apartment
carpet you know
um fishing I don't know what you can
fish there so obviously these so-called
manufacturing or industry related jobs
uh they're talking about within that
industry uh people who work uh with
computers okay so what's increasing are
the computer jobs Okay Internet stuff
and not really blue color work I'm not
sure what blue collar Works they're
referring to they didn't go into that
kind of detail they just mentioned that
blue collar jobs were increasing I'm
saying that's not the case what's
increasing our services in other words
uh computer work internet stuff maybe
phone you know that kind of stuff uh so
here's the trend I've been showing for
some time here's a here it is one more
time okay you can see that we've been
hunter-gatherers for most of our
existence about ten thousand maybe
fifteen thousand years ago we went to
Agriculture and farming uh manufacturing
two to maybe 300 years ago and about
maybe 30 40 this is an old chart by the
way I haven't updated it but the
important thing is the trends and you
can see that maybe 30 40 years ago maybe
even 50 years ago we started getting
more into services
and about 10 or 15 years ago we went
into a special type of service a service
within service an industry with within
an industry or a category within a
category and that is that we've gone
into internet services and that's what's
increasing today everybody's getting
into some kind of Internet type of job
and uh abandoning you know Hands-On type
of services like Landscaping barbering
that kind of stuff that's uh falling
behind a lot of stuff is uh going to be
taken over by chat gpts you know and so
they're they're probably going to take a
lot of jobs in the future and that's
going to squeeze the proletariat the per
person who uh depends on a salary out of
the job market what are these people
going to do well they're going to depend
on government health and government is
going to have to send them a check and
who pays for that well the people who
work they take out of their paychecks
and give to people who don't work that's
the way it works today and obviously the
more people are in the unemployment or
welfare line the fewer people that are
working uh you can see that that Trend
cannot be continued and I think that's
part of the part of the process that's
going to cause the uh collapse of the
global economy
okay but there is a another trend on top
of that and that is that even even these
uh technology jobs as they're called
internet jobs they're disappearing as
well they're kicking people out of those
jobs and here's a a report that came out
a little uh news bit of news says Google
last week announced it would lay off 12
000 people from its staff and it's the
latest big tech company they mentioned a
couple others right Microsoft and Amazon
uh made uh et cetera uh says to enact
Mass Workforce reductions in recent
months and they go over this they say
there have been more than 200 000 tech
jobs lost since the start of last year
okay so uh just keep that in mind maybe
maybe these companies which provide a
lot of the work out there by the way
okay
um not not direct not only direct work
but also secondary work you know
companies that
service them or uh subcontract Etc
um you know you don't want these big
corporations to come down
and again if you introduce into these
big Tech corporations things that you
know robots thing uh
I call them robots uh that do the job
that humans should be doing
um that's even going to squeeze more
people out of the market out of the job
market so I think that's a trend that
you have to be watching you know maybe
not panicking but certainly watching
okay another Trend that seems to be
happening I don't know if this is true I
mentioned this the other day and that's
the UFOs and it says one in five
professors say they had a UFO UFO right
encounter okay and so you see some of
this in the news lately I don't know if
this is a new trend okay here's another
piece of news body cam recording catches
cops investigating potential UFO crash
and they immediately put these uh weird
uh extraterrestrials as a picture you
know to catch your attention
and the question is whether uh there's a
trend now to you know distract people
from other issues and maybe that's why
this is going on I don't know if this is
uh real there's just a fad again and
it's beginning so I looked at the trend
I'm saying um
are there more sightings or is this on
the up and up and this is what I found I
said reported UFO sightings by month and
then you have there by year and you can
see they're they're coming down fewer
people are into it so maybe I'm wrong
maybe there is no upward Trend the only
upward trend is the people who see uh
you know unidentified flying objects
that look like Saturn you know the the
classical disc okay uh people see more
of those out of those people who do see
UFOs unidentified flying objects so is
there a trend uh to distract people from
other issues maybe the economy and so
they put these things there or is there
a real fad going on this is coming back
into being
you know in the news
um my take on this we can't leave the
Earth we cannot save ourselves and
neither could any other civilization
that ever existed or exists out there
today in other words if if there are
Klingons out there somewhere on a planet
which is very very likely okay I think
it's almost impossible that there isn't
okay some other civilization out there
but for them to contact us or be here
having come down here that's impossible
that's simply impossible under the Rope
model okay here's why I'm going to
illustrate it for you okay here's us
trying to escape the Earth we have our
little rocket okay and we're going to
try to leave the Earth and go to I don't
know the nearest star okay let's assume
he's we're going to assume that
everything is nice and peachy over there
you know uh uh pristine Garden of Eden
is waiting for us so we just go there
and inhabit and everything's already
done for us okay and so let's just
assume all that and here's what would
happen okay here's you you trying to
leave the Earth okay uh every atom in
your rocket is including yourself is
bound to every atom on Earth in other
words uh there's a connection there from
every atom to every atom okay so as you
try to leave the Earth okay uh it's not
that you're uh stretching anything okay
so don't get the wrong idea what you're
doing is sliding through existing ropes
that connect the Earth for example to
Alpha Centauri okay so you're gonna go
to this nearest star you're going to go
through these existing ropes okay that
uh attach every atom in your body and
every atom in your rocket to every atom
on Earth and to every atom in Alpha
Centauri okay we're just going to use
this system and what I'm saying is the
farther away you get from Earth okay the
more you get into what I call the linear
region the linear regime okay and here
it is here's a view of that you have the
Earth the Sun and the bird speak and
that long region there between the two
stars is the linear regime okay Proxima
Centauri on one side the sun and the
other as you try to leave the solar
system you enter this region where uh
the ropes are almost as one as a you
know they they come together like a
coaxial and it's an it's a region that
has no gravity no Newtonian gravity
Newtonian gravity only occurs in the
bird speak region
so once you get into the linear regime
uh you know you don't have anything
pulling on you okay and what happens is
like you hit more or less a uh region
where you slow down and you have all
these uh roads just you're you're
sliding through all these ropes all the
way to El Centauri without any pool
without any tug there's no gravitational
pull on you okay from either a star when
you get into the linear regime so
um so so if this is the case we're going
to make that assumption then it's
impossible for any living entity to
travel from star to star intercellularly
that's our
uh view here okay just so you know and
so it's important to know whether the
Rope model uh has any uh validity
whatsoever if that's what's out there
okay
okay another issue uh related to
extension here we have Saudi Arabia
looks to China for business as U.S
influence wanes and yeah what's
happening is that uh Saudi Arabia also
the United Arab Emirates the other day
uh they're all
um kind of ditching the United States a
little bit they're they're trying to
maintain an
um an even-handed position a what used
to be called the third world okay uh
equidistant from Russia and China on the
one hand and from the United States on
the other and this is a significant
change because the United States had a
lot of influence over the Middle East
and I think that is dying a little bit
these countries not are not willing to
follow the United States anymore they
have a little bit of power now uh the
other day the Saudi Arabia and Iran
reached an agreement after so many years
where they were enemies they have
ambassadors in each other's capitals and
they also allowed Syria which was banned
back into the Arab Union and so
uh it's happening and uh it doesn't
favor the U.S interests in that region
of the world and China meanwhile is
buying a lot of oil from uh countries
like Saudi Arabia and others and so you
know they they they're starting to have
more business with China than with the
US and since China can sell them some
technology that's being produced by
their manufacturing processes
uh it's leaving the United States and
Europe a little bit out of the deals so
that's another term that's going on so
keep that one in mind
okay so uh the other day we talked about
some other issue that's going on and
that's uh all this trans issue a lot of
people changing their sex
quite scary can you imagine you know
cutting that thing there
I cannot even imagine that but you know
in the old days uh I used to I had three
sons and I would
I would um tell them little bedtime
stories before they go to bed and I
would tell them stories like from esop's
fables and uh hence Christian Anderson
things of that nature but I also pulled
uh stories out of the Bible okay and no
I did not pull stories like this one you
know where uh Potiphar's wife pleads
with Joseph to sleep with her
uh even though you know uh the girl
looks pretty good so I don't know why he
would reject her uh I think that's more
of a fairy tale okay if you ask me but I
mean honestly unless that's not what the
girl looked like maybe she was fat and
ugly and had hair all over you know I
don't know but uh no I would tell him
stories like of this caliber you know uh
Joseph being sold to Egyptians or to a
caravan as a slave he ends up in
um in uh Egypt he becomes a very
important man and then one of his uh
prophecies comes true and that is that
his brothers and his uh father uh will
one day bow down to him and that's
exactly what happens according to the
Bible uh
did it happen I don't know if it did I
think it's a great bedtime stories and
you'll find lots of them in the Bible
Bible is uh one of my favorite books and
I'm not kidding you there it's a good
book I read it three times completely
from beginning to end you know when I
was young and uh I recommend it to
anyways yeah it's a interesting book not
so much because what it says is truth
uh it's to me it's uh very interesting
because it gives you an idea how people
were thinking in those things what was
important to them okay it gives you a
lot of insight into that so uh there's a
lot of stuff I like about the Bible Old
Testament the New Testament I don't care
about
with the Old Testament I think is a
pretty interesting historical book the
only part of the New Testament is how
religion changed if you look at the Old
Testament compared against the New
Testament yeah religion did change uh
this God this manly God you know with
two feet and a head and two arms Etc uh
he turns into this abstract concept okay
now he becomes love
he becomes intelligence and so on you
know so God became an abstraction okay
so when you pray today well you're
praying to an abstraction not to The God
Who had a who had a magic wand waved it
and made the universe that God is gone
okay not not too many people believe in
that God today even I'm telling about
religious people people who Christians
and so on you know
okay
um so what are the bedtime stories of
today well they're a little bit shocking
so uh right now if you don't want to be
shocked uh turn the your screen off okay
for a few seconds I'll give you five
three seconds one two three these are
the books that you see today okay these
are the Bedtime Stories in my daddy's
belly
so we have the two daddies okay and one
of them has a baby in his tummy okay so
these are the bedtime stories of today a
little bit shocking and uh yeah you
wouldn't have even imagined this in the
1960s or 70s believe in
completely out of anybody's guess in
those days
uh part of the reasons for this you have
people like uh the government you know
they're um
they're somehow spreading this uh from a
propagandistic point of view they're
heavy on equality and so this is
something they're pushing and then I
think they will win eventually because
people will put equality above anything
else
and so what can I tell you uh
the you know the laws are going to
change there's like uh 500 or 600 laws
right now being discussed in the United
States to
um help these folks and or hinder
because there are people on both sides
of the issues obviously and so the
question is uh who's gonna win my bet is
that the people who are going to win are
the people who vote for equality
anything related to equality I think
eventually is gonna Triumph it's gonna
be victorious successful and that's
simply the way it is because they put
that above anything else and they forget
about you know all the other stuff you
know what these people do in bed and
they don't care about all that they say
equality we should treat everybody at
the same level and I think that's going
to win in the end
okay uh so for the new generation this
is these are the type of women you'll
find in the future okay that's what they
look like uh some have transition uh
fellow on the uh far uh right over there
he's uh the fellow who's been
criticizing my theory I've found out a
short time ago that he's transitioning
okay turning into something I did not
know about the sign that's behind them I
didn't know that that was uh the sign of
uh these Trends these transitional
transitioning people okay
okay
um
and so you know I've talked about nouns
here because that's what we need in um
in physics you need nouns what are nouns
nouns are objects only objects can be
nouns in physics you cannot use the word
motion for example the word orbit as a
noun in physics those are verbs okay so
we talk about nouns and but what I've
left behind are the pronouns
and this is the age of pronouns so uh
you know I want to make sure that we
understand that here we have object
right and and those are the things but
as you can see I've never touched upon
pronouns okay so uh what I did I said
you know I have to come up to speed with
what all these people are doing out
there you know a lot of companies you go
to universities and so on and they're
all putting their uh Department of uh
diversity and inclusion inclusion and
diversity you know and they everybody's
put this it's a fad today it's just all
over the place there's not a company I
think that doesn't have that okay so uh
I decided to do the same thing here okay
so I'm gonna put my department of
inclusion and diversity okay
and uh here you have our 800 number you
can call at any time if you have any
help need any help okay and uh so as
part of the deal I'm going to include my
own pronouns I think I have a right to
create my own pronouns so I created the
he She and Him her and she he and her
him okay I think I'm entitled to create
any pronouns that I want okay I don't
see why not uh in fact uh I took a step
further okay so if you're over here and
you want to use pronouns in my site you
better learn all these pronouns you know
we're going to include the days and the
it's in there so that we're covered
completely so that nobody gets offended
okay we want to make sure that uh
inclusion diversity is alive and well
yeah
and uh
I also just in case you know created my
own beer okay we're gonna give that out
to people for free so that they uh come
and visit us I think that's a good way
of creating traffic so just all these
things that we're going to be
implementing here okay
and um
uh follow said in fact several people
had something to say about that subject
and here one fellow says while I don't
think it's it is a loss of genetic
diversity because that's what I'm saying
that causes the primary cause of this uh
phenomenon is right exactly I think it
can influence it I think it's just
rainbow propaganda really this is where
this waves have mainly has affected the
U.S another fellow says you don't think
that increasing levels of astrazine
atrazine uh BPA and other testosterone
suppressing estrogen producing chemicals
have anything to do with it and yet
another one says something parallel to
that says autism is primarily from shots
that have neurotoxic aluminum and other
ingredients
um what can I tell these fellas I think
they're all mistaken they're into
politics and they should do perhaps a
little bit more of research okay here is
uh Calhoun's experiment which I've shown
in the past he put four pairs of mice in
a
enclosure he fed them all the food they
wanted
uh all the water they wanted they were
isolated from disease they had all the
nesting material they had no Predators
etc etc and what happened was that
eventually uh they became autistic and
homosexual not all of them but uh many
of them okay so
um John Calhoun in
utopian Mouse experiment you can look it
up eventually uh produced was one of the
first person to produce homosexuality in
a lab in a controlled environment and he
did it with rats he did it with mice he
always had the same results he did uh I
think 25 at least experiments maybe more
from 1948 to 1975. so he wrote almost
all his adult life on this type of
project were for the U.S army or he was
given a
a lot of land to do this by the US Army
something like that
The Secret of nim you've heard that
about the Mizu escape room lab that
comes from his experiments by the way
it's a cartoon out there
anyways the point is that he produced
homosexuality in the lab
okay and these animals did not get shots
and they did not get uh any chemicals
that would raise their uh estrogen lower
their testosterone any of that stuff
okay and here's another example okay and
this is out there in the wild some
people don't like it but you gotta face
reality okay and here's uh Lions
mountain lions and uh sheep mounting
sheep okay males with males okay and so
the question is you know these animals
receive any shots or were they
influenced by the politicians in their
pride or anything like that
so so you got to keep these things in
mind if in the animal world this is
happening then something else is going
on
and what I'm saying is that what is
going on especially in the case Lions
right okay so the lines you have these
um animals uh they were like 150 000 of
them maybe 50 years ago now there's only
25 000 out there I heard the other day
there's only five thousand Tigers
there's only uh you know uh even fewer
cheetahs you know so all these animals
have a very small pool
to begin with and then they all come
from the same great granddaddies you
know forefathers
um so they have very little genetic
diversity in fact the cheetah I think is
the animal the cat that has the least
amount of genetic diversity in its
species and so what's going to come out
of that you know this is not an issue of
giving it shots or educating them wrong
it's an issue that they're starting
material is pretty bad okay and people
say well they have protection they have
little protection against diseases I
don't think that's going to kill them
it's going to kill them eventually is
that you know you cannot have a brother
marrying sister uh marrying sister when
both of them have the same genetic code
that's you know incest is not favored by
Mother Nature and I think that's where
humans are today we are all incesting
okay whoever you marry today you check
their genetic code I don't care if
they're black or or yellow or white or
brown
we're all in the same boat there's very
little genetic diversity throughout the
human race an example that you'll look
up you can look this up
they ran a test with um
uh what is it chimps and a troop of
maybe 100 chimps out there in Africa
have more genetic diversity within the
troop than all of the the entire human
race eight billion of us
that's got to got to make you think why
is that the case in fact uh no
geneticists can answer that question
they they are puzzled by it they because
they say with eight billion people we
should have more genetic diversity you
know we create mutations every day right
and so they forget you know the uh
bottlenecks that wipes out half the
population and whatever uh mutations
that we created are worthless and so we
are now for the most part we haven't had
too many uh bottlenecks maybe the world
wars some disease here and there's
Spanish Flu here and there right but in
general you know we've been progressing
population wise but we come from all
from the same grandparents
why did they uh why do we have the same
genetic code today why is there no
genetic diversity because our great
grandfathers you know whether they were
in Japan in Africa or in in the Americas
or in Europe uh they went through the
same uh sifting process
imposed by diseases once you pass all
these diseases uh all those who died
they had no protection those who passed
they had protection and they gave that
protection to us so we are as perfect as
human beings as we'll ever get okay
nothing can kill us as far as disease
now because we are all the same
that's the story in a nutshell okay okay
anyways
um
here's uh again uh the Zero D
I'm going to get into that here in a
second give me a second here
okay so here we have the Zero D and
that's not much to talk about
uh what are we saying when we say Zero D
what is the Zero D well according to the
um uh Universal movie which is what you
see there Universal movie has in a
single frame only the static objects and
Concepts and you need at least two
frames of the movie to illustrate
um any Dynamic concept okay so all the
ones on the bottom are Dynamic Concepts
you can see that they take up at least
two frames the one on the top take up
only one frame where should we put the
Zero D I mean uh is this an object is
this a thing
uh Zero D and you know when we Define
the word object we Define it as you know
that which has shape and so what is the
shape of Zero D is it such a monster
okay so that's the issue today
and uh so here's uh what the Zero D
looks like okay get your eyes ready
blink
that's the Zero D okay nothing
okay so this is this is what we're going
to talk about today nothing okay I could
have painted it black also by the way or
any color for that matter uh there's
nothing there
that's the Zero D zero d means that it
has no length width or height no size no
nothing that seems to be the uh
definition of space
okay so
um here's the rundown this is the
mathematicians and this they
uh harp a lot on the word zero or on the
number zero as they go ahead if there is
such a number there's a symbol there's a
numeral but the question is can you
count to zero
you know we can count to one to two to
three no problem there we can't count
the negative numbers to negative one to
negative two right
okay that's an operation that's not
accounting counting you can only count
integers and the question is whether
zero
qualifies as an integer you know is
there a difference between zero Apple
zero rocks and zero trees and zero
houses zero dogs
no zero zero zero there's nothing there
so
you know we start off on the wrong foot
with this Zero D already so here it is
uh these are the mathematicians uh the
Notions they have where they introduce
zero and zero Dimensions okay you have
zero could begin with the number zero is
that is that a number the answer is no
you can't count to zero okay you know
okay count to zero apples
um we have the coordinate system what
they call the coordinate system and it
looks like that thing on the right over
there all those numbers
okay what's the problem there well they
put zero zero
but see the coordinates are used to
locate something
and if you're at zero zero uh what is
your location zero location
I have zero location yeah that's great
okay and uh so no they're not talking
about
um
Zero D uh zero coordinates uh or
coordinates uh where the number zero is
in there they're not talking about
length of their height they're talking
about number lines okay so whenever they
use a zero uh it's hopefully followed by
a whole bunch of integers you know like
one two three four five and they're not
talking about you know coordinates or
Dimensions or vectors they're talking
about number lines
that's why the you know all these people
see no difference between
um
you know uh the time Dimension as they
call it
and the space-time message because
they're not talking about Dimensions
they're talking about number lines
okay uh so zero time you know how long
is that uh how about zero apples how
many objects is that is there a
difference between zero apples and zero
dogs
sounds like it's the same right so
qualitatively there's no difference
zero length
how much how how big is that zero
distance seems like the object itself
you know so so the question is can you
put zero Time Zero Dimension zero length
does that make any sense
okay so what do they mean by zero
dimensions
and one of the starting points we've
always had is the uh the point Euclid
told us something about the point he
says definition one a point is that
which has no part meaning no Dimension
zero Dimensions or zero size exactly
what he meant by that
nobody's exactly sure about it but he
meant Zero he says there's nothing there
and the point is what if it's not a
thing
and if it's not a thing if it's not a
figure if not a geometry does it belong
in geometry okay so that's the question
we have to answer does the point belong
to Geometry at all
if a point is location
it's a representation of a pictorial
representation of location well first of
all you can't represent a concept with
an object you can't represent love with
a heart and likewise you should not
represent uh location a concept with a
DOT you should not confuse them at least
okay either the dot is the point or
location is uh is the famous point and
so which one is it is the point both
well when it's both you're terming cover
both all bases that's what you did okay
you're trying to merge a concept with an
object and that's that's how why the
point fails and that's why they can't
Define it to this day but the line is
breathless length says okay so it's got
no thickness okay the ends of a line are
points so we have two nothing to to
nothingness at the ends of a line okay
and a straight line is a line I like
that a line is a line line is aligned
align the line which lies evenly with
the points on itself in other words the
line is made of Zero Dimensional points
for some reason they call it a one
dimension
uh okay but we're not into the one
dimension we're into zero Dimension
that's what both of them look like the
point looks like exactly like a line
okay because you cannot see Zero
Dimensions you cannot see one dimension
you need these two Dimensions to see
something to imagine something let alone
see it
you cannot visualize
Zero D or the one D okay so yeah Euclid
failed us uh as far as
you know defining the point and
everybody just used whatever definition
he had
okay uh so he continued he he used the
point as the center of a circle so he
defined it as a location he defined it
as
uh a concept okay here it is says a
circle is a plain figure contained by
one line such that all straight lines
falling upon it from one point among
those lying within the figure equal one
another and he was talking about uh some
kind of wheel there you know it's got
all the spokes okay that's what he was
referring to
and he says the point is called the
center of the circle
so what is a point point is the center
it's the location it's not a thing it's
not a standalone thing
okay the point is a center and Center is
the Zero D because what we're talking
about is a concept we're talking about
location
okay so there's there's uh they're
equated okay Zero D location center it's
all the same
uh
important to know that the circle has
changed over time okay here's the
definition that Euclid had he says uh he
looked at it as a bunch of Spokes and
that's not what the circle is today
according to the mathematician said hey
circle is a shape consisting of all
points in a plane that are at a given
distance from a given point to Center in
other words
uh they got rid of the lines the spokes
okay and they just left the little dots
and they said there's a distance not not
a line like Euclid said but a distance
okay
so the line is the distance or they're
different one of the uh other but you
can see that uh Euclid Circle looks a
little different than uh Hawkins there
okay anyways uh yeah the point is the
center of the circle and it's zero D
okay it has no shape no size
it's absolutely nothing exactly like the
Zero D okay it's the center
okay just in case it's important to put
this in here okay you could Define a
figure
right for the purposes of geometry what
is a figure of course we need to know
what a figure is because geometry can't
do without the figure yes I said figures
that which is contained by any boundary
or boundaries
we have a problem because the point
uh is zero d
and so it has no boundary because it has
no size no shape
so the point in fact you did not Define
it
as a figure you did not Define the line
as I figure he started defining figures
starting with planes
okay he he realized that much apparently
you know that what came before the lines
in the points he could not officially
put them under figures okay so he
skipped that step but then he uses the
point to make every one of his uh
figures he uses the point to make the
lines he used at the point to make the
planes and he uses them to make the
solids
what is he talking about he's talking
about location he's not talking about
Point meaning dot meaning a thing okay
he's talking about a concept location
but he's got a different another
contradiction here it is okay he says
the following he says a boundary is that
which is an extremity of anything
so it figures that which is Bound By
by boundary and a boundary is what
contains a figure great we learned a lot
we have this circular set of definitions
between you know number 13 and 14. okay
so yeah we have a problem with Euclid's
definition
and so it's something for you to think
that we started off on the wrong foot uh
with geometry which was the first
religion
the science they caught okay uh it was
an attempt to merge math
with physics
and and that's impossible you cannot
merge those two math first of all is a
language physics is a discipline that
explains
how this universe works hopefully right
and so one has nothing to do with
another it's like saying that uh I'm
gonna explain using Chinese
well yeah you can use Chinese or Greek
whichever you understand better it
doesn't matter you know you can use any
language you want but uh the explanation
has nothing to do with the language okay
in the sense that the language the
language and the explanation do not
necessarily have to merge you can use
any language to explain okay and so
that's where we started off on the wrong
foot we try these people try to merge
math with physics those two cannot be
merged math is a descriptive language
and physics is an explanatory discipline
okay so one has physics is part of
science math is not we don't use math
and science because science is about
explaining and math
explain that's how simple it is and you
just have to Define these terms to find
out where to put each one property
okay so uh they use this term known as
The Singularity scary thing you know the
singularity what is that I mean is this
a standalone object that I can bring to
the conference or that I can maybe make
an image of so that I can show the
congregation out there and say look this
is this is the singularity
no I can't because Singularity is a
mathematical concept it's not a thing
it's not a physical object that doesn't
have shape doesn't have size Singularity
is what Zero D zero Dimensions okay zero
Dimension null okay okay so here we have
uh one example that which is the big
bang and this is what it looks like okay
explodes
okay and it's allegedly what created all
the matter that we have in the universe
today okay so we started out with this
little explosion this little dot that
explodes
and that little dot that's supposedly
the
um
uh the singularity
okay so you know if if we start out with
this Singularity you would think well
okay there's something there
but they say that the singularity is
zero deed it has no shape it has no size
so we started out with nothing ended up
with something they still haven't
explained what the mechanism is for that
um
event that uh phenomenon to take place
how do you explain it yeah they're
saying that something came out of
nothing so because they start with a
singularity and okay I'll concede The
Singularity what is it is it a something
or is it a nothing
and they Define it as Zero D so we have
a nothing that's the definition of
nothing Zero D
okay here uh we have a different version
of that same Big Bang okay it looks
sideways it's going to explode
okay and so we start out with this
little dot that explodes and creates
this
um cyber is looking cup okay
uh the problem is what's the black stuff
I thought that was nothing
I thought that was space
but it turns out that space is inside
the Um this can this glass okay
um that black stuff inside the glass
together with the Stars and everything
else time whatever you want to put in
there that's our universe so what's the
black stuff that gives shape to this uh
this this uh glass
so that's the issue the issue is if the
black stuff is zero D if that's the uh
nothingness right what is the stuff
inside the uh the black stuff inside the
glass and vice versa if the space is
inside the glass what gives shape to the
glass
okay so the Contour has to be accounted
for
okay here we have um
our Universal movie okay so what's
what's the issue with this the issue is
that you know um suddenly you have
something out of nothing that's that's
what it is uh you start out the first
frame of the film hopefully with nothing
and suddenly you have something turns
out the something is ain't nothing as
well that little yellow dot that you see
there is really a singularity
Singularity is looks exactly like the
one in frame one and so the question is
is uh is that the Zero D there
okay so that's the question and of
course what
um uh traditional religions do is they
say well God created The Singularity
okay so God may move this magic wand and
he created Singularity put it in the
universe and from there everything
sprang out and the mathematicians say
well that's not really true that's not
our Theory we don't know what happened
before the singularity we don't know how
the singularity came about oh we know
for sure proven you know it's a fact uh
they say that if you take everything
back once that one day at a time all the
way to 13 billion year or 14 billion
years ago you end up with a singularity
and so the question is where does the
singularity come from
uh the religious folks say God made it
and turns out the famous Singularity is
absolutely nothing and looks like the
one in frame one like nothing
so again we end up with a bunch of
nothings I told you I was going to talk
to you about nothing today
so I don't know when you're listening
okay they also use a singularity for the
black hole at the center of a black hole
in fact the important part really is
that singularity
what is the singularity well you got to
go slowly you have a star big star just
think of it as a gigantic star many
times bigger than the Sun okay this star
collapses gradually collapses on itself
gravitationally collapses right it's all
pulled from the edges inwards
so much so it's got so much manner so
much mass so much compression going on
that it turns into a singularity meaning
it turns into something that has
something that's a big word there
something that has no length with or
high it has no shape no size
that's what a singularity is so at the
center of a black hole you have a
singularity it's a mathematical concept
that has to do with mass runaway Mass
actually and the elephant's gone but his
weight remains behind they're going to
be doing stuff with his with the
elephant's weight
but all the matter of the elephant has
been crushed out of existence there are
no more atoms
okay so let's understand what a black
hole is they usually try to Define it in
different ways with uh escape velocity
no no that's not what a black hole is
black hole is a star that collapsed
completely to a point meaning Zero D
zero size zero shape nothing that's what
it is but the mass is infinite or
whatever okay because they don't like
the word infinite when they're talking
about the mass of a black hole because
if it's infinite all black holes should
be infinite in Mass they don't like that
they have different sizes for different
uh black holes okay so this is what the
black hole looks like you've seen that
they've proven it and so people look at
that and say okay I know what a black
hole is no you don't what you're staring
at is not a black hole what you're
staring at okay let's understand what
you're staring at you're staring at
according to them not me okay this is
according to them matter falling into a
black hole supposedly there's a
singularity a nothingness in the center
of that whole circle circular region and
the bright stuff is simply the light
given off when it passes The Event
Horizon that's what you're they claim
that that's what you're staring at
so this is not a picture of a black hole
because you cannot take a picture of a
black hole because it's a singularity
that has no sides it's Zero Dimensional
that's why you can't take a picture of a
black hole it's black anyways it's dark
anyways so they take a picture of this
and people say okay I do what it is
that's a black hole yeah it looks like a
black hole no no what you're staring at
is matter rushing into a black hole it's
like taking a picture of washing or
water going down a drain and you take
picture of water but it turns out the
drain is Zero Dimensional you can't see
you know once the water is gone you look
and you say well where did he go I don't
see the hole
okay there is no hole because it's zero
d
okay so let's understand that water
going down a drain that is zero d
where did it go and that's the issue
that's what you're staring at there and
that's what you got to explain where did
the matter go if there's nothing there
if there's no hole
the famous hole is zero d
okay
um here you have what people think a
black hole looks like should be the
other way around you know I put it white
so that you would just understand the
concept okay not that it's a white hole
or that black holes look white now it's
that I put a dot there to show you what
they have in the back of their minds of
how they visualize a black hole the
visualize is something
infinitesimally small
infinite testimony small is not Zero D
it's not zero Dimensions okay infinite
tells something small it just means
small
okay there's something still there
there's something that's got shape
that if we had the proper microscope
God's microscope would look something
like that
that would be infinitesimally small in
fact infinite testimony small means it's
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
forever
it never reaches zero size it always
gets smaller that's what Infinity
testimony is small is so the
mathematicians like to use that term
because again they cover two bases it
means something and nothing at the same
time it means that it's zero D Zero
Dimensional and at the same time it has
shape because it's approaching zero
dimensionality
okay we got that
okay but this is exactly what a black
hole looks like if we follow their rules
just like that okay
that's what a black hole looks like
nothing absolutely nothing because they
claim it's Zero Dimensional no size no
shape etc etc
okay so um you say well Bill you
invented all this that's not true none
of that's true black hole is not Zero
Dimensional okay so at this point I need
to introduce evidence Authority okay and
I'm going to step aside I'm going to let
them talk okay so that you don't accuse
me falsely okay here it is okay here's
uh Stephen Hawking and he says Chandra
sector calculated chandraseka was a
Nobel Prize winner as you can see at the
bottom there uh calculated that a cold
star of more than almost one and a half
times the mass of the Sun would not be
able to support itself against its own
gravity
would it collapse to infinite density
infinite density means no volume
okay means Zero D zero size no shade
fact there it is Eddington was shocked
by that implication and he refused to
believe chandraseko as a result
Eddington thought it was simply not
possible that a star could collapse to a
point
Point Zero D Euclid's point you know no
size
Einstein himself wrote a paper in which
he claimed that stars would not strain
two what zero size that's what these
people are talking about
and uh they gave the Nobel Prize to
chandrasekar for proving that a black
hole is zero size okay and then we have
this other uh gentleman he's
um from a university and he says on
solving the equation with a particular
value of central density you will get a
model of a star with mass m and radius R
plot r as a function of M and show that
R Falls to zero
falls through zero the radius Falls to
zero when m is equal to the Chandra
sector Mass
okay so what are we talking about radius
of zero there's nothing there Zero
Dimensional zero size zero shape if you
can do all these then you have repeated
the calculation for which channel sucker
won the Nobel Prize
so what did the mathematicians prove and
give Nobel prizes out for for proving
that a star collapses to zero size and
All That Remains behind is its mass
infinite mass or or because it's got
infinite density right because it's got
zero volume that's why it's infinite
Mass okay so this is a mathematical
calculation okay and again let's
introduce more evidence because people
say well that's just Stephen Hawking
what did he know okay let's go with
another one says the black holes radius
is zero one person another fellow says
the point of zero volume and infinite
density okay creating what is known as a
singularity what is a singularity zero
volume infinite density that's what a
singularity is zero D okay
we're talking about the zero Dimension
we're at the zero Dimension but you may
say well that's just two okay let's find
out some more here zero size up to uh
mathematian a true mathematical point
when another person says collapses
totally talking about a star right
um to a singularity which is what a
point which has zero radius
okay it is impossible to see a
singularity no kid Gotta Have a good
eyesight to see nothing
okay so um
just in case other people rub it in from
a different point of view but say the
same thing in different words uh they
say that a black hole crushes all matter
out of existence there you have three
references you can look them up okay all
these people believe that the star okay
the known as a black hole gigantic star
that is collapsing under its own weight
under its own gravity uh collapses to
zero size crushing all matter out of
existence in the process so that
eventually they end up with a
singularity which is zero Dimension zero
size no shape okay so let's understand
uh what we're talking about when we talk
about zero dimensionality big bang and
black holes especially those three right
okay so this is what it looks like okay
you see the star okay think of this as a
star
the gigantic star and over time it
collapses to
nothing
okay so it's it doesn't end up with a
point it crushes all matter out of exist
and ends up with nothing with zero d
and until you get that through your
skulls you know you're going to have a
trouble understanding what a black hole
is and what kind of uh BS they're uh
trying to sell you okay the
mathematicians
to them it makes sense because they just
deal with numbers to a physicist it
makes no sense whatsoever so if you're a
physical you're a rational individual
you're going to reject this notion of a
black hole okay
okay so what's the problem with uh with
what they're saying well they have all
this matter right you're going to crush
it out of existence okay you don't turn
it into zero size uh infinite density uh
no shape okay and so here it is we have
a little circular argument there because
a black hole uh crushes is made out of
mass right
um but uh mess is the quantity of matter
that's how it's defined so we say Okay a
star has all this matter the quantity of
matter that's what we call the mass we
measure it in kilograms but the man but
kilograms is a measure of how much
matter the star has okay a gigantic star
millions of times bigger than the Sun
great no problem okay so now this matter
because of its own weight because of its
own gravitational
attraction towards its center it's
collapsing in on itself so it's
collapsing collapsing compressing
everything in there until all matter
disappears all manner disappears okay so
Christians all matter out of existence
we have no matter but if they say the
mass remains behind
they crush the elephant out of exists
and not a single atom remains but the
weight of the elephant you know is still
there and is causing all kinds of
problems to stars or whatever is out
there so we have a contradiction because
if mass is the quantity of matter that's
how they Define it in this context right
and if that's what mass is the quantity
of matter we crushed all matter out of
existence
how do we still have mass
that's the issue so they have a
contradiction they have a circular
argument
okay
these are things you got to keep in mind
okay so um it's funny because here we
have
um
uh NASA and what does NASA do well NASA
talks about the sizes of black holes
okay and I don't know how you can
imagine this because if a if a black
hole is a singularity a singularity has
no size what sense does it make to talk
about sizes of black holes and this is a
video that uh you can look up at Nasa it
came out recently here it is I'll show
it to you yeah I'll show it to you in
fast motion uh because they show it in
slower motion but here it is
and they're talking about sizes here
okay you can see that
[Music]
um
they're just zooming out and they're
eventually going to show the biggest
black hole in the universe which is
bigger than all this combined at which
you're staring at
okay so ton 618 is bigger than all that
stuff that you just saw that's what
they're saying that's how big this black
hole is
so what are they talking about let me
show it one more time so that uh
so that if you missed any part of it uh
you can see it again uh what are we
talking about we're saying that we have
this black hole which is bigger than
several galaxies put together that's
essentially what they're saying and
that's uh this ton 618 here it goes
again
you can see our little Sun there
compared to
the solar system first
and then you have other
galaxies nearby
and this thing this black hole they say
is bigger than all of them put together
Milky Way there you have you know
Andromeda
and with all that this
gigantic black hole is bigger than all
of that how can that possibly be if a
black hole has zero size in other words
The Singularity what are they talking
about
okay well when they talk about sizes
they're not talking about bigness like
shape they're not referring to shape
they're referring to
uh Mass
so when they talk about size they use it
in terms of mass not in terms of shape
so when you talk about size you know
size of an elephant you're saying well
this elephant is bigger than that one
what you're talking about the C
you don't say well because if you're
going to talk about weight you say let's
wait I'm gonna say well this one weighs
more than that one
that's not what they're saying or has
more mass than that one you know more
atoms yeah
but that's not what they're saying to
use the word size
they give you an idea or they try to
convey the idea that they're talking
about shape this that this one has a
bigger shape than these other things
that's what they're saying okay
and um and so here you have one uh
individual and he says the following he
clarifies to us he says talking about
black holes in terms of sizes inherently
perilous mostly because of gaps in
language ah we talk about things like
size when they don't really apply
because we don't have a better way to
describe them absolutely a lie you know
we have a way of describing them but
they want to use the word size in the
wrong context on purpose to mislead you
and to mislead themselves they're not
talking about side they should simply
talk about more mass or weight or
whatever they want to talk about in
mathematical terms they're not talking
about size they are deliberately
misleading you and misleading themselves
when they use the word size the true
size of a black hole even the largest is
impossibly small that's kind of their
whole deal even the most massive black
holes are in fact quite small just
singularities in space-time which harbor
so much mass they'll happily swallow
anything and everything that comes into
grabbing distance when we talk about the
size of a black hole what we're really
talking about is the diameter of its
what event horizon and those can reach
truly incredible sizes okay so they're
talking about the region of influence of
the singularity okay Singularity is it
zero size the if it's zero size and has
no matter then it has no influence over
anything
but they created this um
campfire
notion okay it looks like this
okay when you're in a campfire okay
you're sitting around it you have this
fire going on
but the fire isn't just constrained to
where the wood is you know the campfire
really extends uh the heat extends Way
Beyond you so you can think of as the
fire as being the Zero Dimensional
Singularity if you can turn that into a
zero D but the important part here what
what they're talking about size they're
talking about the region of influence uh
so to speak the heat of the campfire
okay so the region of influence and how
far it extends is what they call the
Event Horizon and that's when you have
this escape velocity issue okay so they
call the black hole the whole thing not
only the singularity at the center but
also the region of influence and that is
what is so misleading about what the
mathematicians do because they're not
really talking about physics they're
talking about a region of influence of
something which has no size no matter
how can that affect anything it's it's
again the k case of the water running
down a Zero Dimensional drain once the
water is gone you say well where's the
hole well there is no hole because it's
zero size and zero size means you still
have the sink and no drain
you have forgot to put the drain in
there but the water rushed through there
that's what they're trying to sell to
you okay and they use words like
infinitesimally small instead of saying
the correct word zero size zero
Dimensions okay and yeah so they you'll
see Infinity
small uh they crush it out of existence
they use those terms and you know what
they're talking about really is the
vacuum nothing okay we're talking about
nothingness throughout this whole thing
and so what is the Zero D well Zero D is
absolutely nothing it's the point which
is simply a location
is not a thing so you can't talk about
dimensions in terms of in terms of
location okay location has no Dimensions
okay so I don't know why they call it
the zero Dimensions uh the point uh or
zero Dimension
um it's also a synonym of Singularity
what is the singularity it's what is a
the center of the black hole and it's
what gave birth to the universe maybe in
the Big Crunch we end up in another
Singularity okay so they use all these
terms and what are they talking about
they are talking about nothing that's
what the Zero D is uh zero length that's
absolutely nothing what's zero time
absolutely nothing what is zero Apple
zero three zero rocks that's absolutely
nothing and they're all equal so they
like the zeros okay but zero means
absolutely nothing you can't count to
zero so Zero D to summarize is nothing
and so this whole time I've been talking
about
nothing
okay let's move on to our uh questions
comments that people made one file says
if all atoms in the universe are
connected by ropes and there are 10 to
the 80 atoms in the universe that would
imply each atom would have 10 to the 80
ropes attached to it okay good that's
math okay that's a lot of ropes per atom
okay yeah okay so it's a lot many much
okay also some ropes would have to
stretch from one edge of the universe to
the opposite Edge okay am I missing
something no I think you said it quite
well I think you described what we're
talking about so you regurgitated the uh
The Proposal the hypothesis the Rope
hypothesis I'm not sure if there's any
question other than that but yeah
uh you're not missing anything uh the
ropes converge Upon Our atom and there's
gazillions of ropes uh I wouldn't say
it's 10 to the 80. I would say 10 to the
thousands to the millions I think uh
it's uncountable the number of ropes
converging upon an atom
and you say how can that possibly be
and again uh you're thinking of touch
see and touch but primarily touch and
this is what trips up to everybody
everybody's thinking of touch
and our Oaks have no ability to touch
you have no ability to touch a rope the
Rope has no ability to touch another
rope so they can superimpose no matter
where they are in the universe you can
put gazillions of rope
ropes on the same axis
so
no question I guess yeah he just said am
I missing something no you're not
okay you get it right down okay another
fellow says or ass or Commons you say
I'd say shadows and Reflections are 2D
but they don't exist independently I
guess that's that uh uh caveat for 2D
second dimension right another fellow
answer is yes shadows and Reflections
are 2D having no depth okay depth is not
a dimension but okay we'll allow them to
use the word death there and definitely
is a vector but he probably wouldn't
know the difference shadows and
Reflections aren't just conceptual
residing in the mind or minds of humans
as abstract ideas 2D geometry cast 3D
we got cast from 3D
uh yeah Shadow is not a thing Shadow is
light okay Shadow is simply light
and so we have to distinguish between uh
a thing and what the thing does okay
uh here's one way of putting it
uh rope is a thing it's an opting a
thing
okay here's a rope that's what a rope
looks like for those of you who never
saw one go to a hardware store ask for a
two-strand rope and it'll give you
something similar to this hopefully okay
so you can take it home and you'll find
out that it's an object it's a thing
and that's what we're saying that this
object looks like okay that's the
general shape of this thing okay two
pair a pair of twined uh threats
very simple very thin elongated threads
that's what they are that's what we're
proposing that light is that's the
mediator of light what does that do it
torques there's torsion
okay it Turks in place
so you don't need
um to send little bullets like in
quantum mechanics from one atom to
another it Twirls in place and therefore
by truly in place you get the signal
instantaneously almost at the speed of
light 300 000 kilometers per second at
each end at each atom that is connected
to that rope okay so we have to
distinguish the object which is the rope
from what it does which is torsion okay
torquing
okay so uh just so we understand where
we're at another fellow asks or Commons
he says space has shape
[Music]
if you have a cube in the almost perfect
vacuum of outer space that's composed of
27 small cubes three columns three rows
three cells okay there I try to picture
it okay remove the center Cube we'll
assume that black one there is the hole
that it left behind okay
uh there's a space that has length width
and height in the center
that space
okay we don't know if that space has all
we know is that the cube has the space
that you haven't shown that it's got
length width and height because if you
remove all the other cubes uh you won't
have any length with or height
ultimately all this energy space and
it's certainly not conceptual reciting
in the mind or minds of humans as
abstract ideas exist physical presence
yeah space equals no physical presence
okay that's not what space is but that's
a description uh you can't you can't
define something like space or Concept
in the negative now you have to say
space is that which doesn't have shape
meaning I cannot Define it as the
absence of something okay
uh we cannot have one without the other
what's in between physical presences uh
has shape well the issue is can you have
a standalone cube of space
uh right now you've shown is that uh the
the the glass has water in it not that
it uh that the part above into the water
um is is an object the water is an
object that's inside it not the empty
space above it and with this pillow is
trying to tell you is that the space
above the glass of water is a standalone
object and the issues the the answer is
no if you take the water and the glass
out you won't have that space there okay
so there is no such thing as space and
in this case here you have these 27
cubes if we remove the cubes will we
still have a cube of space with length
width and height the answer is no
Okay so
again the question is is the glass half
empty or half full more or less that's
the issue
okay and another fellow says he says uh
well he sends me to a video okay it says
uh that talking about waves and the
funny part is as soon as you get like
less than a minute into the video he
says this the fellow who made the video
says I don't have a clue what an
electron looks like or what mass is or
charge or spin really are
well that's a bad way to start a
presentation I mean if you don't know
anything what can you teach
and yes these people who have hundreds
of thousands of visitors and um
and subscribers uh
uh very few people go through the Narrow
Path of Knowledge many people go through
the Wide Open Spaces of ignorance that's
what it amounts to
anyways with that we'll see you next
week